um let's say it's more than two so in
the example that i gave and that we were
talking about there's one cell and then
the external world but obviously the
world is much more complex than that and
let's just imagine slightly more
complicated there's two cells and then
an external world
is it always the case that from the
perspective of one cell you may as well
just
treat the external world even though it
comprises an external world plus another
cell out there can you always treat that
as its own singular black box such that
we can always understand the dynamics as
two black boxes or is there ever a need
for a third a fourth a fifth
i i think i think there probably would
be a need to go if out there if the
external states
are themselves
partitioned into things so if my my
universe
is um composed of external states that
can
themselves be carved into natural kinds
you're like other artifacts and objects
and air
planets liquids
natural kinds as soon as you talk about
a natural kind you're talking about a
kind of thing as soon as there is a
thing that's in play there's a mark of
blankets so what that tells you is in
principle it was possible to take
all the states that constitute say an
eco niche
and this
find identify
the thing of interest say
say me
and my internal states and so and then i
would um identify my blanket states and
then i got the rest of the states but
now i can start again i can find another
set of internal states and identify its
blanket states and then take those
states off the table and then start
again and recursively tile all the
external states so that now i've
eliminated effectively external states
and replaced them by the internal and
the blanket states of all other things
and in on that view
what happens is that because
there's a
um
a statistical
insulation or separation of internal and
external states by the blanket states
that means i can never see your internal
states i don't need to know your
internal states
because everything that is
knowable about your internal states is
on the surface on your blanket states
what so now the picture that emerges is
an ensemble of things
natural kinds
um that are coupled to each other
via their blanket states
no no no individual particle or person
or thing
and
will ever be have access to the internal
states of anything else
but there will be
coupling and influences that are
mediated by the blanket states the
active states
and possibly the sensory states
mathematically you can actually have the
sensory states also influencing the
outside but for simplicity let's let's
assume that sensory states do not
influence external states uh it is just
the role of active states to actually
couple back to the outside you mentioned
something extremely interesting and i
want to pick up on this you said that
the sensory states can influence the
external states at least that's not how
i understand it so how can a sensory
state influence an external state so i
said that
mathematically it is that is possible um
so if you if you think about um
your from a pure from the point of view
of um
um somebody who's trying to understand
the statistical behavior the
probabilistic behavior
of a set of dynamics described as
differential equations or your coupled
systems
then the name of the game really is to
ask
you know what
statistical dependencies that define a
markov blanket specifically um a markov
blanket renders the internal states
conditionally independent of the
external states given the markov blanket
so that's their role that's what that's
what is implied
by a separation of the inside from the
outside that all you need to know
is the blanket states because given the
blanket states the inside and the
outside are conditional independent
so the question now is what kind of
sparse coupling among
all the states at hand
give rise to
that conditional independence that
definitively specifies the markov
blanket
it so happens that all you need is the
following rule
internal states
can only influence themselves and active
states
external states can only influence
themselves and sensory states that's all
you need so with that
condition in place you now immediately
have a markov blanket or a particular
partition
from that follows the conditional
independence and therefore the
interpretation of the
autonomous dynamics which is a
description of the trajectories or the
paths of the processes taken by the
active and the internal states of a
particular
of a particle
so
that means that it is actually
mathematically allowable
in the sense that you don't you do not
destroy
that uh that markov blanket or the
statistical properties of that markov
blanket it is allowable for the sensory
states to influence uh active states and
you may be thinking mom that's a bit
silly you know and there's no way in
which my photoreceptors or my
uh you know my the cochlear implant
materially affect the outside i think
that's absolutely true so for things
like you and me
and
then you would not normally expect the
sensory states to influence the external
states
but that's not the case for much simpler
things
when
when you look at much simpler things
where
most of the dynamical influences the
coupling that we're talking about you'd
write down in terms of the differential
equations the launch of an equation
um
most of those influences are basically
short range
so you know we can preclude action at a
distance for example if you're a single
cell
you know unless you're next to me i
don't really know what you're up to
i'm having to exclude here all sorts of
interesting things about long-range
electrochemical communication and
electrical gradients and the like but
let's just take um a bag of cells um
that
that just diffuse stuff locally they
just
they touch each other and that's the
only way that they can they can
influence each other is by
being proximate in some euclidean space
so everything short range now in this
situation you have a very different kind
of structure so here the cell the
sensory states are the cell surface
and when these active states that lie
underneath the cell surface
change the environment they do so by
pushing the cell surface
into the external milieu and cause
changes in the sensory states the
surface states of other cells so
being a cell is probably a good example
of where your sensory states which just
are your surface states
um actually do all the heavy lifting in
terms of changing the outside the
spatial
spatial relationship with all the other
cells that you're co-inhabiting a
particular organ uh for example
so
you know it's a little bit
counter-intuitive um but i think a
really interesting um sort of you know
thought experiment um and actually a
practical uh consideration when it comes
to
looking at the different ways in which
um
insides coupled to outsides and the
nature of interactions between the
internal states of something in the
external states of something
and we sort of take it for granted that
we can do action at a distance you know
uh literally i can talk to you in canada
while you're talking live in london um
you know that that that is that is a
beautiful example of this action to
distance
um that
means that you know we have quite a
special um
kind of coupling between our sensory
states and our active states that is not
um
a gift
of very simple um cellular-like
structures or automata
that can't interpret signals um or be
subject to or be sensitive to
influences uh at a distance just so you
know or for people who are listening and
if this wasn't obvious enough the free
energy principle is famous for or
perhaps infamous for being somewhat
inscrutable for people who have a
physics background or math background
what would be the minimum prerequisites
this is how i like to conceptualize the
podcast before i interview someone i
think about okay what are all the pieces
of knowledge i need to know prior to
interviewing them so obvious example is
let's say qft you need to understand
classical mechanics or invariants
quantum mechanics perhaps bundle theory
if you want to understand yang mils and
so on properly so what would be the
prerequisites for someone to properly
understand the free energy principle
let's say if they have a math or physics
background
it wouldn't be
it would be probably much less than
you'd expect to encounter
a university i think you'd certainly
need to know
um sort of you know
the basics of variational calculus and
it would be really nice if you
understood where a lagrangian come from
came from
and uh to understand the simplicity of
action you know basically you know
exactly hamilton's principle of least
action and how that inherits from path
integrals of lagrangians and
how that arises from um
dynamical systems theory of a very
simple sort where you can write down any
random dynamical system as you know a
stochastic differential equation or a
launch valve equation
i think
that's probably quite sufficient you
know what um what you would need i think
um
to
appreciate all the interpretational
richness afforded by
what happens to
the paths of least action when you have
a mark of blanket you need to know a
little bit of probability theory you
need to know what a conditional
distribution is you need to know uh the
important you know what have an
intuition as to what is meant by
model evidence for example or marginal
likelihood so
you know whether
with i would imagine you know a week's
um
um foraging on uh wikipedia you could
probably acquire that if you know if you
felt flu if you were fluent already and
sort of um
in path integral like formulations of
the kind you can find on wikipedia so
that you certainly wouldn't need
you know what sort of bundles where you
wouldn't need category theory you
wouldn't need to know anything about
gauge theories um
you you know you wouldn't even you
wouldn't even you need to know about
lagrange multipliers
yeah but you need to know um
you know
the basics of how to
how how to understand um differential
equations with you know with random
fluctuations with a probabilistic
stochastic aspect to them and how you
can understand paths of least action uh
in these kinds of systems